good morning um the time being 10:03 on
the 24th um I would like to um bring
this subcommittee to order um
uh I've been around here for a number of
years and the task that we that this
subcommittee is facing
is incredibly difficult and I'm not
really sure there is a workable answer
these bills don't belong here they
belong a few hundred miles south of here
and Washington because this is a problem
that is a national problem affecting
every state it is not only affecting New
Hampshire and only because the US
Congress has not been willing to step up
to the plate um we in this state are
doing what has happened in a number of
other states and we're trying to do the
best that we
can um a number of us have worked on
this listening to people in the public
listening to information that we we
received and I can tell you uh
definitely that the people who worked on
the Amendments that you now see before
you no one is completely happy and
therefore I think think we might have
done a pretty decent
job
um what we tried to do is pay attention
to what was happening in other
states be as close as we possibly could
to that to make it a little easier when
the time comes for the US Congress to
decide what to do but we had to honor
some differences which makes sense in a
small
state um you have before for you that i'
I've distributed here in the room uh
draft amendments dated the 2 uh the the
22nd of the month and I must say that I
violated one of my basic rules I wrote
that it was a draft I put the date but I
did not put any names on there um and um
so I'm sorry about that but this is
these are proposed amendments that the
chairman of the full
committee uh chairman Lynn and the chair
of the
subcommittee me um uh would like to
jointly introduce to the full committee
if in fact the subcommittee agrees um I
also want to add because all of this is
a moving Target there is there are some
additional
changes um that um chairman Lynn is
going to bring to our attention um that
aren't in these amendments uh but at
least you can begin with some written
copy that might keep everybody on the
same
page
um and I am indebted to all of you who
have let us know what you consider
important or what changes you would make
and also to um uh representative f one
of the uh co-sponsors of the bill and to
um former uh representative Kirk for um
using a lot of their time to help us get
as close to yes as we could get so with
that I would like to um present to you
um uh the these two amendments that are
headed um draft
Amendment with the date of
10:22 and they they're both separate and
nonetheless relate to each other and
which is why each of the bills was sent
here um so with that
introduction
um I think um I think the next thing I
would do um um to share the wealth here
is to ask um chairman Lynn if he would
begin with the house bill House Bill
314 um and then do that first and then
we can go on to um uh the Senate bill
and uh repres uh chairman Lynn if you
would perhaps you could highlight some
of the key um differences
yes
AB thank you so
um uh I guess the the um the first thing
I would say and I and I'll go over um
the um house bill um 314 the proposed
changes first the the thing I would say
at the outset though is one of the
things that we were concerned about
because these two these two bills do
have some some overlap as I think
everybody's aware and we wanted to make
sure that we we were we weren't
having anybody subject to both bills we
weren't in other words somebody that's
going to be regulated we didn't want to
have them kind of subject to both bills
so the only thing I would say I'll I'll
talk about 255 later but the one thing
that I would say is the the The Entity
that I'm going to talk about now that
will be covered by um uh 314 House Bill
314 are by language that's been added to
255 which I'll talk about later are
specifically excluded from
255 so um that's uh and and it's a
pretty substantial a pretty significant
exclusion which I'll talk about um but
anyway so let me let me turn to 314
as you may
recall by way of
background the original
bill
um purported to
establish um a an expectation of
privacy
um that appli to that applied to certain
information and then it all and it and
it it
then dealt went on to say that the that
governmental
entities um can only obtain private
information from what are referred to as
third-party providers in certain ways
and then there was a um there was a
provision that
um purported to that
uh at least arguably would have allowed
causes of private causes of action
against both the government and private
private entities and that was the
subject of some of some uh some concern
I I I had proposed an amendment that
change that but what we came up with in
three in the in the amendment to
314 that you have before you is a
um
that basically applies only to the
covered entities and let me talk about
initially what the covered entities are
because this I think this is
particularly important um you'll see in
par in um what has been designated as
proposed RSA
57i um uh in in Roman numeral 2 it
describes what the covered entities are
and it just and it refers to them as
third-party providers of information and
services and it basically goes on to say
that it means the
following the uh the follow people who
provide or individuals who provide the
following kinds of services um cellular
and landline telephone electric water or
other utilities internet service
providers cable television streaming
services social media Services email
service provid iders Banks and financial
institutions insurance companies and
credit card companies now that's a
pretty good pretty good list of of uh of
of entities um but it's it's nowhere
near as large as the entities that were
that uh would be covered by
255 um then uh in uh section i1 Roman
numeral 4 um there is a definition of
what available to the public means uh
because information as you'll as I go
through this you'll see information that
is made available to the public uh that
that is available to the public is
basically excluded from this in other
words it's if the if information is
available to the public in accordance
with that with the definition here then
it's not considered to be personal
information um so subsection then we go
on to subsection I2 of the bill that is
really the heart of the bill and
essentially it says uh I'll just read it
an individual shall have a reasonable
expectation of privacy in personal
information as that's defined um in the
in the definition section including
content and usage given to or um or held
by a third-party provider of information
and services and not available to the
public third part party providers of
information and services shall not
disclose personal information of an
individual to anyone
unless
um one of two one of three conditions
exist first such individual has given
explicit consent for the disclosure to
one or more of of the information to one
or more others secondly an emergency
exists where there is a danger uh an
imminent danger of of death or serious
bodily in a serious physical injury to
an individual
or substantial loss or destruction of
privacy of property if the information
is not disclosed or third the
information is disclosed in accordance
with the provisions of uh sections I3
which I'll get to in a moment in
section I uh I2 Roman numeral 2 we've
set out what specific requirements of
what needs to be met uh for consent um
and it provides that um as you'll see
that it is an
optin requirement of consent now that's
different notice that that's different
from what is in 255 which again we'll
talk about after but this is an
optin consent provision and it requires
that if a if a provider of information
is going to request consent from an
individual um the um the request for
consent has to be sent has to be
communicated in a simple clear and
unambiguous form and must State the
purpose for which the consent is sought
the consent communication has to be
separate this is a big I think a a big
point the consent communication has to
be separate from any other communication
that the provider sends so it can't be
you know
we're 35 pages of gobble deuk and one of
them says uh you know I cons uh by by
responding to this I consent it can't be
that and then the last the last thing
and this is I think probably the heart
of it the communication must be
structured so that the individual is
required to respond by performing an
affirmative act to opt in to consent so
um uh so then I
um in there's I want to make sure that
right last minute change is on is on
that okay it's on this file okay all
right so I'm gonna talk about I'm G talk
about this and then okay all right yeah
that's a good point so uh this is
255 this is this
is so um
then
all right so so then in I3 let me turn
then to to section I3 which provides
this is this is the
one this amendment is different from
earlier versions of the bill in that
I3 it now
describes when a provide a covered
provider can give information to when
the request for the information comes
from from a government entity but bear
in mind this is different than the
earlier versions which were aimed at the
government entity the in other words the
the the the way the earlier version was
drafted is it said the government entity
can only get information in certain
circumstances this has changed so it
doesn't apply to the government entity
it applies to the private provider but
what it say says is if you're a private
provider that's covered by the Act and
the person that's requesting information
from you is a government entity you can
only give it to the government entity if
if the if it meets the requirements of
section three so um the first one is uh
when when requested to do so by a
government uh investigative regulatory
administrative or adjudicative body um
acting with in its Authority the second
when uh is when required to do so by a
subpoena uh duly issued by a government
regulatory body or um uh uh or or
administrative body um acting within the
scope of its Authority or by a duly
impanel grand jury or by a court um the
third one is when compelled to do so
pursuant to a duly issued search warrant
or pursuant to a judicially recognized
exception to the warrant
requirement the fourth exam subsection
uh 3 I
I3 uh Roman numeral 1 D when requested
by uh by the division of emergency
services and communication for purposes
of responding to or assisting with
emergency uh 911 Tel uh
telecommunications and uh then e in an
emergency where the immediate there's
immediate danger of death or serious
physical injury to an individual or
substantial loss or destruction of
property requires the disclosure without
delay of personal
information uh concerning a specific
individual a telephone number username
or other unique identifier and where
judicial process cannot be obtained in
time to prevent the identified danger
um the subsection two of i3
uh provides that a third-party provider
of information and services who
discloses personal information to a
government entity pursuant to one of the
one of the uh five uh situations that I
just described shall contemporarily
provide notice that has that it has done
so to the individual to whom the
information
pertains unless first the government
entity seeking the information demands
that such notice not be provided and
furnishes to the provider uh the uh
provides the gives the provider uh the
basis of of of the governmental entity's
Authority uh to make such a demand or
second a court has issued an order that
such notice not be given so in other
words the default position is if the if
you're a provider and the government
says give me certain information and
assuming that that it's within one of of
the five Provisions that allows the
government to get the information the
provider the provider can comply the
provider must comply um but the com the
provider has to give notice to the
individual that it pertains in other
words you know Mr Smith uh you should
know that the uh the the government has
asked for certain information to be
turned over to you um to uh to them uh
relating to you and so we've done that
um that has to be done contemporaneously
unless one of the situations um is uh
that that is described in that section
uh would would prohibit it so for
example if it were a grand jury request
the the the the the prosecutor
presumably would say or may say don't
disclose this information because it's
covered by Grand Jury secrecy if if that
applied and grand jury secrecy not
wouldn't necessarily apply in all
circumstance ances but it might very
well apply um importantly subsection I4
of this uh provides that no third-party
provider of or of information and
services may require a waiver from the
provisions of this chapter as a
condition for any individual to do
business with it so there it's got to be
you know it's got to be a real waiver uh
not not that if you w if unless you wave
this when not doing business with you
and then section five is the remedies uh
section and one of the big things as as
many of you may know one of the big
things for me was uh my concern with
with both 255 and 314 was the prospect
of a private right of action um you'll
see in I5 that we have eliminated the
private right of action the Attorney
General is allowed to enforce
um uh the statute and to invoke the
provisions of the consumer protection
act which provide for uh in the um in
um in the case of actions brought by the
Attorney General the the the Attorney
General may may seek um civil penalties
or actual uh or up to $1,000 in actual
uh I'm sorry actual damages or penalties
up to ,000
um for for each violation of the chapter
um so that's that's um
314 and I should say
I've yeah Le I'm was going to talk about
the changes that
I've the ones that are in here yeah so
you know what the one the the proposed
amendment that was
distributed I'm sorry sure just stop for
a minute
um uh as I said at the beginning
nobody's completely happy which is why I
think these might be good um uh the
private right of action has always been
something that I thought made a lot of
sense because um we are talking about
the individuals who choose to live in
this state and should have the rights
guaranteed to them under the state
constitution however um in trying
to to do the best that we possibly could
do in a world with disperate
views we let that go
um in what we're proposing to the
subcommittee now in addition um because
um chairman Lynn
um uh has in fact now is approaching his
uh one fourth
year end of his second term in the
legisl lure he still by and large keeps
close to his heart and his brain his
responsibilities that were developed
when he served in another branch of
government and because of that he read
this and then said okay but if we're
talking about uh the consumer protection
act where do we say that and the
question is was a legitimate question so
after these drafts were
prepared um then chairman Lynn wants to
present to us some additional
changes and so those don't appear in the
draft that you have seen they do appear
in another draft that there might not be
any need
to to distribute to you but which um the
Chairman's going to explain now is that
I think that's the right background so
that the the the subsequent draft that
that uh uh representative Smith just
referred to what what it changes from
the one I just went
is I just want to make sure I'm right on
this
uh ABCD yeah ABCD yes so what it changes
is if you go to the one the one I just
went over that I just went over and you
go to section um 507
I um
3 Roman numeral 2 so that's where the
the changes start on the one I'm about
to talk about now so what I was think
when when I finished the drafting of the
one we just talked about I I really sort
of said well wait a minute you know
don't we that that as I just explained
said you have to provide the inform the
the the provider who is who gets a
request from the government to provide
information has to give contemporaneous
notice and as I was thinking about that
about 4 o'clock in the morning one
morning over the weekend as I was
obsessing about these uh amendments um
it seemed to me that I was that um what
I forgotten is well what I what I
thought about was well wait a minute why
should it be only
contemporaneously particularly if you're
talking
about a request in the form either of of
a of a request from a government entity
or of a subpoena from a government
entity why shouldn't the um why
shouldn't the government entity be
required not to demand production of the
information for a reasonable time so
that if the if the individual who is the
subject of that request has thinks that
he or she has a basis to object the
individual has time to go to court to
make the objection so in in subsection
in the new amendment that I'm going to
talk about now in subsection I3 Roman
numeral 2 it says and I'm when a
government entity seeks the disclosure
of information from a provider of
information and services pursuant
to uh sections 3 one A or B and that's
one a is the request and 1B is when it's
made by a subpoena the request or demand
for such information shall not require
production of the information sooner
than 10 days from the date the request
or demand is made
within so that's that is that that is a
change in that it's a that is now a
restriction on the government it says to
a government agency or even a grand jury
or whatever it says to whoever from the
government is asking for information if
you issue a subpoena for example you
can't demand production in less than 10
days um and it goes on to say within
five days of receiving such request or
demand the provider shall notify the
individual to whom the information
pertains that the request or demand has
been made so that such individual has an
opportunity to pursue judicial remedies
to prevent compliance with the request
or demand if there are valid grounds to
do so however there's then a provisor
provided however that no such notice
shall be given if in the first instance
the government entity seeking the
information demands that such notice not
be provided and furnishes the provider
with the the basis of its authority to
make such demand or two a court has
issued an order that such notice not be
given so that if they you know if the if
the uh if there are legitimate reasons
for example the grand jury subpoena that
might be that might be one uh under
certain circumstances for the government
to say no we want
no no Bank of America we're issuing you
this subpoena but we we don't want you
to disclose to Bob Linn the the person
who whose records they're asking for
that that that the grand jury has made
that request they can say we have the
authority to do that and and the bank is
required not to give me notice or if a
court has issued an order saying don't
give any notice so then Ro Roman numeral
3 of that section deals with the other
three the other three circumstances in
which the government May request U
information and that's in the case of a
search warrant or an emergency and so
what it what it says in those
circumstances if it's a search warrant
or if it's if it's one of the emergency
situations then in that circumstance the
the provider has to give contemporaneous
notice not advanced notice but
contemporaneous notice that the that the
search War has been executed or that
such an or that they're giving over the
information pursuant to an
emergency and again that section has the
Proviso that if the that if the if the
government entity has the authority to
to demand that um the search warrant not
be disclosed or if a court has issued an
order um demand uh requiring that the
search W not be disclosed or that the
emergency not be disclosed it's kind of
probably would be difficult to imagine
an emergency but maybe that could happen
um anyway and in those circumstances
then no disclosure um is made um so I
think I I guess what I'm saying is I
think the the latest amendment is is
just a little more complete it it sort
of it it sort of
um deals with what happens um when when
one of these requests by the government
is made
what does the pro what what uh what are
the constraints on the the government in
making the request and what does the
provider who gets the request have to do
Visa the individual that's the subject
request now you can take a deep
breath could I have that yes of course
um members of the committee um what I'm
slight
amendment as
um further explained by chairman Lynn I
am Crossing
off in this very official way um the
cover page because the cover page makes
it seem as if this is the bill that had
been presented to us with all the
numbers on it and I don't want people to
be confused but if you
could so and this will now can now go to
the public
um so
the the first page is just crossed off
with all the numbers and codes and
whatever but um the rest is here and
somebody could just
come okay let me know if that's not
enough yeah okay um thank you
representative Kirk um so this amendment
then includes all of the
changes um that were in the first one we
presented to you plus the addition one
dealing with
consumers and now I would like to ask um
the committee
members um if they
have any comments or
questions or if they would like to hear
Andrew there we go thank you madam chair
yeah my only thing on these amendments
is I believe no matter what our opinion
is here and now they should be both
taken to the full
committee because it just should be
voted on by everyone oh um of course the
the process as always is that the
subcommittee would make a recommendation
to the full committee on November and if
we can do that today then we as a
subcommittee will not be meeting again
if we can't do that we would meet again
as a subcommittee we have to prepare a
recommendation to the full committee um
on November 8th the chair uh chairman
Lynn has called for the full committee
to come together for a work session and
where it is appropriate for an executive
session to vote on all of the retained
bills um and if we can get through that
process on the 8th so be it if for
example the full committee suggests
other amendments or other changes that
would have to be considered those would
be
um prepared and then we would come
together again on the 15th to um to take
our final votes um on all the bills that
had been retained by this committee
those bills would then go to the Full
House and uh they would be voted on on
the 3 on or the fourth or if it goes on
forever and ever on the 11th um
and so you're absolutely right and
fortunately New Hampshire being I
believe the only state in the United
States that does this um no bill ends up
without having been voted on by the full
house so are you okay with that
representative
Andress okay
meanwhile this doesn't have to be cast
in stone yet um
and the the Suns in my eyes but I can
imagine I know who would like to ask a
question
representor am I getting a reputation
um just a specific thanks for sharing
this language because I was I was trying
to put the pieces together of what you
were saying which sounded sounded very
reasonable so am I reading that this is
there's
a 10day waiting period before you give
it out but five days after the demand is
made
before within that period you have to
give the notice to the per to the person
who's the recipient so so is it the
intent that there be 10 days for that
person to to object or because it seems
like in this instance maybe they only
get the five days no that's right my
intent was to give only five days
because I think that this this is my my
intent was this is some particularly if
it's you know if it's a if it's a
request for a government agency I can
just from my own prior experience um
there can often be the government's in a
hurry and and and often for good reason
the government's in a hurry and so um I
I guess I thought that 10 days to
comply in other words 10 days to demand
compliance was a
was probably you shouldn't go beyond
that and therefore in order to give the
person at least five days to object um
that's that's why I that's why it's
worded the way it is so that the the
let's say you're the let's say this is a
subpoena to a bank so the you know the
bank gets a subpoena it says provide
direct provide the information on Lynn's
bank records uh and it has to say if you
know if if today is the 24th it can't do
it for 10 days but now I'm the bank I've
got to give within five days I've got to
give notice to Lynn that by you know by
the way we've got a subpoena to saying
to turn over your records and we're
going to do it on on day 10 um unless
somebody tells us not basically unless
somebody tells us not to and then what I
can do is you know I can go get my
lawyer and say wait a minute they
subpoena me they there's no basis for
this I want you to move to quash The
subpoena and and the my lawyer
presumably or me would have 5 days to do
that yeah thanks that's how I read it I
just wasn't sure if that was how what I
was correct in whether that was the
intent so that thank you no that is the
intent yes any other questions from us
um would the members of the
subcommittee
um be interested in hearing any
reactions from others in the room or
would you prefer at this point
to focus within the subcommittee on our
discussions let me reward that does
anyone have any objection if there is
someone in the room who would like to
add a comment or ask a
question all right is there anyone in
the room who would like to add a comment
or ask a
question and I begin by reminding you
that um we do not not live in a perfect
world and no one is claiming that this
is perfect um uh and so I want you to to
keep that in mind um uh go ahead I know
I should remember your name but I've
just forgotten it I'm
[Music]
sorry I'm Matt Schwarz from Consumer
Reports thank you so I mean I'll caveat
all of this that I just saw these
amendments this morning so so I might be
misconstruing things but I have some
initial
thoughts
um you know on
255 I think that since the last time
we've met the exemptions kind of make it
wait a minute we're only we've only done
we've only presented HB 314 right now so
we haven't done anything with 255 we'll
get to that once we finish um 314 sure
because they are two separate bills
although related to each other and for
those of you who might have been late
and not heard the interest the
introduction if you are covered in one
of these bills you are not covered in
the other in order to make clear the you
know the differences in in how we were
pursuing this so now that you know we're
focusing first on the house bill do you
have any comments on the house bill and
if so great and if not you can come back
when we get to the Senate bill yeah okay
it might be better to talk about them
together when we discussed them both
because yeah they're very intermingled
and and how they they deal with things
so I'll I'll let you talk about 255 I
have thoughts on 314 but they make more
sense in in light of what happened with
255 okay so you don't want so you'll do
that when we get to the Senate bill yeah
now yeah have you had a chance to look
amendment I don't want to shut
off any debate um you
know we're trying to do the best that we
can so if anybody has anything please
let us know all right I don't see anyone
else what about anyone else on the
committee do you have any
questions um about um what the we've
attempted to do here with these two
bills and in order
to
um try to
um actually play the role of Solomon
without a baby being present um and uh
thank goodness
uh but trying to again reinforce that
this doesn't belong here at all it
belongs it belongs in Congress but we
are going to fulfill Our obligation to
the citizens of the state by doing this
anything else no I I guess you know I
just want to I would make a comment I
really want to um I mean I I given where
we started out on these bills
and the really wide disparity of
views um I I I just want to express my
thanks to the to uh the chair and to
representative uh Kirk former
representative Kirk and representative
Earth um I really think that we you know
this was a this was a significant
compromise all around people coming
together and I
think you know at the LA at the risk of
s ort of my tooting the Horn of the four
of us I think we did a pretty fair job
of of compromising and coming to a point
where at least the four of us can agree
now you know the the the rest of of this
subcommittee you may have different
views and maybe the whole committee will
think we're all wet but I hope they
don't um and so I um you know I feel
like I'm I'm I'm happy at the progress
we've made and I thank you madam chair
and I thank you um I I because they are
separate bills unless you have an
objection at this point I would like to
ask the
subcommittee for um its
uh recommendation to the full committee
on the house bill
314 um are you do you feel at this point
ready to make a recommendation to the
full committee that will review do this
on the 8th of
November
um so if one of you would like
to uh make a motion I would be so
inclined to accept
that so is it appropriate for me to make
the motion or should somebody else well
I think representative tur might be
willing to yeah I'd like I'd like to
make the moot motion to um accept I
guess the amendment um as as distributed
the the revised Amendment as distributed
Rec in the last draft okay and is there
a
second okay so moved by tur and seconded
by Andress um and
discussion if not not um I think we
could probably just do this by a show of
hands rather than a roll call so if you
are in favor of the motion to
present the
version with the scratch door first page
hand okay so that is unanimous so 314
will go
on to the um to the full committee and
what will be before us that day is a
newly
drafted version of this um with the
proper
headlines okay now let's go let's
go from here to the Senate
bill and
um so I would like to open up discussion
um on Senate Bill
255 um
where we are
acknowledging I think very very
significantly the differences between
the two bills and who they apply to
understanding that we hope in each case
we are honoring the rights to privacy of
the citizens of the state in the way
that is
not the most
ideal so let's see representative Lynn
why would you like
to this is a
different kettle of fish or balll of wax
or something would you like to present
the Senate the changes that we're
proposing in the Senate Bill yes thank
you madam chair um so um let me uh go
through it
um sort of line by line if you will with
that the changes are reflected in
bold um so I think the
first the first change that you will uh
see is in
section five I want make sure I'm right
on that that I haven't missed something
um yes in in section 507
H2 um you'll see that um we've changed
the threshold applicability that would
be on page four line 23 of the draft
amendment that you have before well it's
actually line 24 of the draft amendment
that you have before
you and and so it says
um that um during uh that this that this
bill is applicable to uh to persons that
conduct business in this state or
persons that produce products or
services that are targeted to residents
of this state that during a one-year
period um a controlled or processed the
personal data of not less than 35,000
it's reduced from 100,000 to
35,000 unique consumers and and we've
added the word unique because what we
want to that that is designed to
prevent it's designed to make it clear
that if if you know if if I'm if I'm the
consumer of some business and I and I'm
the one that makes that deals with the
business 35,000 times in a year that
doesn't mean that the business qualifies
it's got to be 35,000 different
individuals um that that in order to in
order to qualify um and so that so it's
reduced from 100,000 to 30 to 35,000 and
then as the second trigger uh it would
be or or controlled or processed the
personal data of not less than
10,000 unique consumers uh and derive
not more than 25% of gross revenue from
the sale of personal debt um so that
that's a that's uh a significant change
um then you will see the next um the
next change and this is this is the
change that accomplishes what I talked
about four that is removing from this
bill the entities that are covered by
314 so it adds um an exclusion in RSA
H3 one it adds a new section Roman
numeral 1
G um and that's on page five line four
of the draft that you have in front of
you and that's for indiv and you'll see
that this
definition uh is virtually the same
almost word for word as in uh three um
as uh as a definition in 314 individuals
organizations or legal entities which
collect personal information about an
individual in connection with providing
the following kinds of uh Services
cellular and landline telephone electric
water or other utilities internet
service providers cable television
streaming services social media Services
email service providers Banks and
financial institutions insurance
companies and credit card companies um
so those people are
excluded from
255 because they are covered by
um page six line 21 right then this is
uh uh in you'll see that in this
section uh uh H3 Roman numeral 2 there
are listed a bunch of of uh of uh
organizations that are that are not
covered uh or types of information that
are not covered and what we've done is
in response to a request by uh
um someone repres who
represents um someone that provides that
that that sells uh chemicals that could
be precursors for control substances
they asked that we add an exemption
because they are required by federal law
to provide certain information so that Q
the new proposed subsection Q of that
says personal information maintained or
used for purposes of compliance I with
the regulation of listed chemicals under
the federal control Substances Act so
that's I mean that it seems like that
made that made perfect sense to add that
the next change is in subsection uh
H4 and it's in Roman numeral 2
um you may
um you may recall that in the original
Bill there is a
um requirement that the um controller of
information have establish a um a
procedure for
um uh exemptions uh for a procedure for
for uh somebody to say I don't want my
personal information given out um under
the original bill that was decide that
was established by the controller
of the information we've changed this to
say it's the secretary of state that
will describe this procedure and as
you'll see in other sections that I'm
that I'm going to get to the idea of
this is so that the secretary of state
will will establish one
procedure for people to be able to opt
out this is in this in this bill it is
an opt out rather than an opin provision
but this says the secretary of state
will establish one procedure that all
covered companies are to comply with so
we don't we change that what would would
have been allowed under the original 255
that basically said look company a can
have this procedure for opt out Company
B can have this company C can have this
we basically said the secretary of state
will establish a procedure that all
companies that are subject to this must
comply with and that seemed to me again
this is this is one of the areas of
compromise I you know the perfect world
I might have said n maybe something else
but I I I can I understand the argument
on the other side and I think this makes
uh perfect sense in in that Spirit um if
if I could interrupt at this point for
just a moment you will see as you
continue to read this section that the
word
controller
appears and and it should you do not
think that that should be taken out um
and
substituted uh with Secretary of State
it is the controller who's going to have
to apply
this but the standard will have been
established by the Secretary of State
very very good point that's exactly
right um and you'll see then that that
that the reference to the Secretary of
State also appears
in uh RSA 507 H Roman numeral 6 I'm
sorry H colon 6 at in Roman numeral
3 uh which reads A a controller shall
provide consumers with a reasonably
accessible clear and meaningful privacy
notice meeting standards established by
the Secretary of
State and then goes on to goes on for
further requirements and then in
subsection that same uh subsection Roman
numeral 5A says a controller sh shall
establish and shall describe in a
privacy notice consistent with the
requirements of the Secretary of State
one or more secure and reliable means
for consumers to submit a request to
exercise their U consumer rights
um all right
uh
next haven't missed anything um page
16 20 yeah okay so right so I
the so this um now we get to the
enforcement section and you may recall
in the original Bill there was a
requirement um that the
uh that the Attorney General give uh
someone who was was ENT a covered entity
that was alleged to have violated the
bill the Attorney General was required
to give that entity the option to cure
which was a subject of some some debate
uh in the committee so what this what
this does is to change that and actually
there I had proposed an earlier
amendment that was we we had discussed
but never had it hadn't come up for a
vote but it basically says that during
the first
year after this bill becomes takes
effect as law during that first year yes
the the Attorney General must give the
um the
U The Entity that is alleged to have
violated the uh statute an opportunity
to to cure but after that first year
it's it's the the Attorney General does
not have to give it but has the option
to give it so that's uh that's
um uh kind of consistent with that
earlier amendment that I had talked
about and it in subsection three of of
h11 it then it it the the the original
uh version is change so that it says in
the circumstances that is after January
1st of 2026
after the Bill's in been in effect for a
year it then describes when the Attorney
General is going to exercise has the
discretion to to allow cure it describes
the factors that the Attorney General
should consider in deciding weather to
allow an opportunity for cure um and
then the last change and this is in
subsection Roman numeral four of Section
h11 um it it says uh nothing in this
chapter shall be construed as providing
the basis for or be subject to a private
right of action for violations under
this chapter and the words or any other
law has been added which is which is
what a um a number of the other states I
believe Connecticut and the other states
also have added this and the purpose of
that is just to ensure that somebody's
that we don't you know clever lawyers
don't say well yes we can't there's no
private right of action under this but
uh we're bringing our action under the
you know the consumer protection act or
we're bringing our action under
something else um and therefore it's
okay this is designed to capture that
there's no basically make it clear
there's no private right of action
period full stop um so that's
um that's that's really it um and as I I
say I think the L the most significant
change is the change that cuts out from
this bill the entities that are covered
by 314 that's and I you know I think
we'd have to concede that that's a
pretty significant a number of people of
entities that cut out um but um it's the
kind of entities that it seems to me
there's a particular interest in
preserving in
protecting the privacy of information
that those entities hold about
individuals um and and
therefore um they should be subject to
the more onerous requirements of
314 um and you know in in particular the
requirement of an optin for that kind of
information as opposed to an opt out so
with that I'll shut
up thank you so that you can see this is
the much longer bill but um the changes
are
probably a little
more easy to understand um anybody on
the committee have any questions
point is there anyone in the audience
who would like to make constructive
comments to help
us find our
way yes Mr Schwarz this time I
remember
thank you again for allowing me to speak
match words from consumer reports for
the record and thank you for your
continued work on this legislation and
we appreciate that a lot of these
discussions are being held in public
with the opportunity to comment and that
doesn't go unnotice and it's
appreciated so again I'll start with the
caveat that I've just seen the
Amendments that we're talking about this
morning and so I could be totally
misinterpreting things
but I think the simplest way to sum up
my thoughts about both of them both of
these bills that we were talking about
is that they do pretty different things
and I don't think that they are
necessarily have appropriate substitutes
for each other um you know we came into
these discussions on S SP 255 thinking
that we wanted some you know narrow but
substantial tweaks um that could make
that Bill had a more actionable and
workable for consumers um one of those
things was lowering the threshold so
that the bill would actually cover
businesses in New Hampshire that had
collected substantial amounts of
information
about uh consumers um and we're happy to
see that that amendment was included um
but I think in section 507 H2 the new
exemptions kind of you know we we talked
about this they are
now kind of um completely eliminating
from coverage the businesses that we
think that this legislation is intended
to cover so um the bill now exempts
businesses that collect personal
information in connection with providing
a cellular service so that's Verizon
your phone
company um information in connection
with providing electric water other
utilities internet service providers
again that's companies like Verizon and
Comcast cable TV streaming services that
collect a lot of information about us
like Netflix and Hulu and then I think
probably most notably of all for us is
the social media companies would now be
exempt as we know those are the
companies that collect the most you know
can I can I no I'm sure yeah I'm sure go
ahead so assuming that your firm with
wanting optin protections for those
types of businesses which is now
contemplated in HB
314 I don't NE necessarily see the logic
of continuing to move s SP
255 or you know to put it another way
excluding from 314 the Protections in
255 that are very detailed and and would
create a lot of protections for
consumers so um you know that includes
stuff like providing a right to access
correct and delete those are kind of the
Baseline consumer rights that are in 255
and wouldn't be in
314 um and there's other aspects of 255
that aren't reflected in 314 as well you
know doing risk assessments for high
risk Pro uh processing of data having an
appeals process if you're um optin is
rejected or you feel like the company
isn't honoring your requests um and so
now we kind of have 314 without that
stuff and we have 255 and it's kind of
unclear who 255 would apply to now um I
think there's likely a pretty small
Universe of companies that aren't
covered by those exemptions and but
nevertheless would be collecting that
amount of information and now you're
putting on those companies which are
like companies that are likely to still
be in 255 are probably going to be
mediumsized businesses they kind of now
have all of these owners requirements
that I think a lot of people when they
were drafting this bill were thinking
would apply to the biggest companies
um and so I think there might be a
little bit of a mismatch there um you
know and then in
314 the whole concept of the opin hinges
on whether the business discloses
information to another person um just
from a drafting perspective I I didn't
see that disclose was a defined term um
and so that if you want to continue with
3114 might be something to look at
because that's going to be a heavily
debated area what does disclose mean
does that mean to sell does that mean to
share um that's a term that would
typically be uh defined and and same
thing with with the recipient a person
uh isn't defined term in the bill either
um another thing on 314 I would just say
that I think it might be a little
confusing for just the average Joe
reading this you know the the framework
of that bill says that the still social
media companies and all the companies
that we Exempted from 255 are third
party
collectors that doesn't necessarily jive
with the fact that those are companies
that are directly collecting information
from
consumers um so I think that just might
be another kind of confusing drafting
aspect of the bill um yeah I you know I
have a lot of jumbled thoughts but I'll
I'll probably stop there and um I guess
I'm just kind of left with the
impression that uh more work would be
needed to to make either of these
workable that you left with the
impression that what that I think more
work it would be necessary to make
either of these workable now that we've
kind of um Exempted a large segment from
one and added it to another Well th
thank you very much for um for your
comments I understand that you haven't
had time to
um look at at this proposal um um and
Ponder how how to make it better and I'm
very sympathetic to that and I also
understand that you have a very
important focus in terms of the consumer
um and and respect that very much um I I
do have a question that I'd like to ask
you you know we in um in Hampshire think
about what happens when you build a wall
what you're Walling in and what you're
Walling out um and
uh
uh what we try to do in this draft
and uh perhaps we
completely failed I always willing to
recognize that is
to figure out who we were Walling in and
who we were Walling out we did not want
to
have
[Music]
um uh companies in the private sector um
be confused
about um what they were supposed to do
we were trying to make it as simple as
possible we recognized the
differences
amongst uh the private entities who
would
have reason to have access to
information and hope that we divided
them in a way that made
sense um
um I'm just sitting here thinking of my
wonderful father-in-law who said um he
didn't make the capitalist system but he
does try to live by the rules and the
irony of course is it's very hard to do
that
um I do want to point out to you and
this follows up on something that
representative Andrew uh said earlier
this small group will go to our full
committee we will then go to the Full
House and if in the fullness of time the
bill passes the bill would then go to
the Senate and open again to
improvements fine-tuning that might give
you some time Mr Schwarz to figure out
the wording that you think would be best
and and that's because we do operate a
pretty open system here um longer speech
than I plan to give but I did want to
thank you
for being very honest and saying you
haven't had time to really go through it
but these are questions that you have
and you're not sure about the answers
and I respect that very much does anyone
have any questions or comments for Mr
Schwarz yes representative Lyn yeah no I
share what the chair has said and I you
know I understand that we're kind of
catching you without having had a little
chance to sort of look at this carefully
and and you know you may if you may have
further comments or thoughts as this
goes on the one thing I guess I would
say
is I you know I your the concerns that
you express about things
that companies that would now be
excluded from 2 55 the the the the
things that a company that is subject to
255 needs to do and your concern that
we've now taken a number of those
companies out of it um I mean that's all
think provides the answer to your
concerns is what we've said in
314 is those companies can't disclose
they they're in other words all of the
the the the things that you want
protection for in
255 I think 314 essentially says no
there's no if you've got private
information fine um but you you can't do
anything with it so to speak unless
there's been an affirmative consent um
right yeah so in terms of the opt-in
versus opt out I think that's true and
you yeah plenty of people would make the
argument that that opt-in is stronger
than an opt out I guess what my point
also is though is that 255 does a lot
more than just determine the optin
versus opt out question like I said it
gives all of these other Baseline rights
the right to access correct delete your
information and now we're carving all of
those companies out from having to
provide even though those Baseline
rights so I think that is a a starter
problem another problem is that you know
bills like 255 we have issues with them
but they also have thought about these
issues very thoroughly and so you know
in three was it 18
34 uh 314 yeah in
314 yes you make an op in for uh for
consent but then there's nothing about
what a receiving entity is restricted
from doing if they if the comp if the
consumer opted in so like a bill like
255 addresses that by saying that a
controller has to make you know
contractual agreements with their third
parties and processors that prevents
those entities from doing certain things
when they've received information and
that type of kind of Downstream uh data
transfer uh ecosystem is not kind of
contemplated in in 314 at all kind of
just says like yeah you can opt in to
consent and then it doesn't put any
restrictions on what a recipient of of
that information would do so that's
just um me pointing out that there's
kind of a larger kind of legal landscape
that has been left out if once you take
those entities out of a bill like
255 oh yes no no no you raised you those
are very good points that you just
raised let me let me just ask you this
um this would be a subject for for the
committee obviously to have a further
discussion but
what one of the thing one of the big
things that we were concerned about is
in drafting the the the two bills and
the the two amendments the way we did is
to not have a
company that be subject to both U
because they you know that could create
confusion but as I hear what you're
saying would it correct your
problem if we
said
um
in in 255 If instead of
removing from 255 all the companies that
are cover CED by
314 we left them in
255 but simply
255 is intended to
exempt any companies covered by
314 from complying with
314 yeah yeah I I think that makes a lot
of sense um so then they have to comply
with they have to comply with both with
both but they're dealing with separate
issues I mean one's about what you do
with the consumer's data and the other
one's about if you can give information
to the government so I always kind of
viewed these bills of having separate
aims and so to take one tranch of
companies out of one and put it in the
other I think that then you're not
neglecting the other issue okay so I
think they can and they can comply with
both I
think
so that would be the only wording that
would change in 255 is to have it comply
with 314 is that is that what you were
saying yeah I mean basically it would in
other words I think what it would do is
take the the let me
find let me find the language that I'm
talking about
um page five page five uh five at the
um well you know what you might have to
in what I have in mind you because of
the language I have in mind you might
have to it might not fit in in G but but
in other words it would be language that
would say something
like
um nothing in this
chapter shall prevent uh nothing in this
chapter shall
excuse a company subject to
314 from complying
with uh
314 um from from from complying with 314
and and and it might also have some
language saying that um something like
you know if um companies that are
314 are are required to comply
with
whichever what with whichever uh uh
chapter either the one covered by 255 or
the one covered by 314 which affords the
greater privacy protection to
individuals so I think that you know
again I I'd have to think about the
language a little bit but it would
essentially it would say that companies
can be subject to both 255 and 314 but
if they're within the orbit of 314 then
they have to comply with its greater
restrictions some companies won't be
within the orbit of 314 and so they'
only be subject to 255 but some would be
subject to
both and of course you understand we
won't be using 314 or 255 but we would
be using because those bills would cease
to exist what we we would be using are
right yeah and I think there I mean I'm
happy to look through it but I think
there might actually already be language
in 255 that kind of reserves a
business's like ability to respond to a
a legal request or something so it might
there might already be something in
there that accomplishes a purpose but I
look thank you anything else yes
representative ch
uh just adding on I I I think that was a
great discussion around around how these
two interact in ways I I'm wondering
also um since the 255 has the sort of
universal opt in or opt out sort of
concept built into it whether we should
also consider how that would interact
with the opt in provision of the other
bill um so that if you opted if you
universally opted say in uh you know
across the board would would you still
be afforded the right to be notified and
opt out it's just just the thought that
builds if we if we go down that route
but um but I like the ability to
universally opt out to be applied
because it takes the burden off people
to constantly you know make decisions
stand
thank you any other
comments any other
yes you have to press get the red light
on there you go great thank you um my
name is David Miller I'm a resident of
straford County and uh today I'd like to
speak both as a resident but also um on
behalf of an organization called restore
the fourth um it's a nonprofit uh
advocacy organization um for restoring
the strength of the Fourth Amendment uh
in terms of protecting uh private
citizens data from government intrusion
and three now that 314 is in scope here
I think Matt was presenting Mr Schwarz
was presenting on uh the rights of
consumers from the private sector and uh
I do want to thank the committee for uh
strengthening um what I think uh Federal
Senator Ron widen has been trying to do
for a while is preventing the flow of
information from the private sector to
the federal government um restore the
fourth is I don't want to be picky
absolutely but are you here um as a
lobbyist oh uh would that sorry if that
would classify me as a lobbyist I will
leave out that angle and just present on
my own behalf um I I think that um
unless you are registered as a lobbyist
oh I see um
uh you might want to speak to yourself
and you can certainly acknowledge that
there are groups out there that are
concerned with this issue oh okay but
just you know because these records um
are kept you don't want to misstate who
you're representing here officially sure
yeah okay I'm sorry for for my La
familiarity I just want to you out of
trouble I yeah I've uh um not a member
but I have corresponded uh with them
about their thoughts on some of these
bills and let me represent myself then
resident of the state thank you so much
for informing me um all right so uh
representing myself as a um resident of
straford County um I uh have um of
course had limited time like everyone
here to uh review these bills and I
thank very much the subcommittee for
acknowledging that that uh might make
things a bit difficult for us uh but um
I just want to provide a little bit of
context for why it would be so important
to ensure that the um rights uh not just
of opt out but of amendment um uh corre
so correction of inaccurate records um
deletion uh and not just opt out from
transfer but also deletion uh and the
other enumerated uh rights in 255 are so
important to um apply to all companies I
understand that the wording that
representative Lynn has suggested could
end up being a little bit more
complicated because um adding a single
section not fully exempting those other
entities that have opt-in requirements
might sort of conflict with the wording
in 255 regarding opt out requirements so
just to sort of provide additional
motivation for why it's so important to
add this additional wording and I I
agree that uh representative L suggested
wording is excellent and would probably
address most of the concerns here um
data Protection Law uh in Europe at
least dates back from about 1970 in the
German state of Hessa in 77 nationally
in Germany doesn't seem to have affected
their economy adversely um and uh
already in the 90s was passed on the
European level and the main intent there
um was to prevent ultimately um
government and private sector abuses of
um personal data by regulating the
entire Downstream data
flow to describe this more
fully um of course we cannot uh regulate
who we transfer data to out of state
because of the dormant Commerce Clause
um and we cannot regulate um what
foreign jurisdictions uh New Hampshire
operating company transfers data to
because that's a exclusively under
Federal Authority um and uh typically
the downstream transfer of data um in
Europe is regulated by having a list of
uh jurisdictions where the data
protection laws are considered adequate
to similarly protect the information so
if you have a contractual Clause that
says you need to have strong protections
if it's in a country where the legal
system wouldn't actually enforce that
contract obviously it doesn't protect
European residents data in New Hampshire
we can't do all that and so it becomes
important to have a consistent mechanism
of restrictions on the downstream
transfer of data so if you have
different regulations as would be
proposed in the current written text
presented to us this morning three for
certain sets of companies versus
others you draw a graph basically some
arrows between the different companies
and what data is transferred and there
end up being holes where certain
categories of data can be transferred
under certain conditions and it becomes
possible to use the loopholes that
result uh to to end up with data
reassembled out of jurisdiction in a way
that is adversely actionable by
companies or government against citizens
so in order to make those data flows
regulatable by the state of New
Hampshire it is necessary to cover as
many of those entities as possible with
that basic list of Rights first of all
the obligation that contractual
commitments have to be made for
Downstream flows which is covered by 255
and not by 314 and also that it every
stage of those flows New Hampshire
consumers which there a lot more
companies covered now with a 35,000 uh
uh um uh threshold so I thank the
committee for adding that as well um you
have to uh make sure that all those
companies also allow an individual to
correct their data If it's incorrect or
to delete it um and all the other
so-called data subject access request
rights um so I would support uh 255 if
this um am if the suggested Amendment
were introduced one more thing
quickly um on a technical level um and
on privacy level I'm very concerned
about one of the three insertions of
mentioned of the Secretary of State I
absolutely agree that the Secretary of
State should set
guidelines um on the uh procedures and
user flows uh however I am concerned
that is a secretary of state defining a
single type of mechanism uh to
technically strained for all the
different companies uh to allow the opt
out and the reason for that is this in
European
legislation
uh you a company is not allowed to ask
for additional proof of uh for example
an identity document or the identity of
the individual or let's say their New
Hampshire driver's license um in order
to show that they are the person who is
making the request whatever is the
normal mechanism for logging into to
authenticate to the service is has to be
adequate because otherwise you're
passing a privacy bill that encourages
additional collection of
information by those people who care the
most about their privacy and clearly
that will discourage them from pursuing
their
rights so that restriction is not
present in either of these bills and
asking the Secretary of State to specify
a user flow technically that every
company has to follow means that it
would be the same procedure for a
company that already knows that that
knows the user by their email or another
company that got the data from a third
party and has to verify that the
individual has a certain ID and that
would not be appropriate thank
you thank you very
much it's clear that you're quite
knowledgeable about what's happening all
area um any other thank you any any
questions for Mr Miller not thank you
with again for being
else okay so now we have
um we have the Senate
bill and um what differs for our
subcommittee action now is that in the
house bill we had this version that we
could vote on right now there seems to
be a
suggestion I think there is a suggestion
um of ways that we could improve the
bill and on
my right sitting here I see um the
former Supreme Court Justice are working
hard on his
opinion um to give us language I don't
want to rush you
do you think you have language now that
you would be comfortable asking us to
include in our proposed amendment or do
you need more time you know what I I
think let let me let me this is a really
rough draft but and so I I think it I
probably would not be appropriate for us
to vote on this language because there
might be you know I as I think about it
more I might have some some other but I
think what I what what I think would
make sense and I ask anybody in the
audience if they have a you know a
different view to to uh if they think
there's something missing from this but
suppose the language in
255 said something like
this companies that are covered by
255 and also by
314 shall comply with both statutes with
the exception that to the extent there
is a there is a conflict between these
two statutes companies that are subject
to
314 must comply with the statute that
protection so that that I think would
say for examp that would say that
companies that are subject to 314 that
that which is the opin um
they they have to comply with the 2 all
the 255 things about correcting your
information getting your information you
know knowing having your information
deleted they have to do all that um but
they also if they're whereas 255 has an
opt out Pro provision whereas 314 it's
opt in if you're one of the companies
one of the more limited companies that's
subject to 314 you have to comply with
its greater privacy protection which
would be the opt in as opposed to the
opt out I think
that that would would
um would would do it um and I'm I'm just
wondering if uh this is my it's okay of
course this is my suggestion um we can't
in the amendment it makes no sense the
amendment for us to use 255 and 314 what
the amendment would have to do would
have to be drafted um in such a way as
to refer to the RSA
sections um because the independent
existence of the two bills
disappears um and so that requires you
know some
careful uh review to make make sure that
we have the right sections in there so
this is my
proposal
and you don't have to agree of course
um my proposal would be that we asked
chairman Lynn to
draft to come up with the language that
is appropriate to be
added to uh
um he uh he's free to share it with all
of us but we can't discuss
it in private so you know that's all
what that would mean then is for the
purposes of
today um and I of course would be very
um we leave today's discussion of 255
saying that um we are comfortable with
the draft Amendment with certain
additions and that would just be our
report for this meeting and that we come
together
at
930 which is always very good for
um representative Divine she likes
nothing more than 9:30 in the morning
um
um uh well I mean to be here um and that
or even at a quarter of 10 on the
morning of the
8th and we having seen the language
before would be ready as a subcommittee
to vote on it and assuming that we can
accept that Lang language then we would
be free on the 8th to present to the
full committee the amendment that we
agree on other than that we would have
to have another meeting and all while I
love your company and I'm sure you love
mine I don't think any of us need extra
meetings um does that does that meet our
requirements so
we can work on that language we would
then get it to OS what we would have
then to vote on on uh a quarter of 10
even on on the eth would be the final
language you will have seen it before
but we would not have discussed
it um and then the full Committee in its
work
session could review that does that does
that meet everyone repres I can't see
you does that is that okay with
you
okay that being the
case we are ready to send to
OSS
um uh
314 as amended in the way that we've
agreed to to get a final Amendment and
then
um we will work on this change which we
would then send to OS for them to have a
final Amendment and those amendments
would
be
um in the com in the subcommittee's name
or however ol will you never can tell
what they'll say but um I mean you know
who knows
um uh whichever name is appropriate and
we would then come together on the 8th
as a subcommittee for a few minutes to
approve the final language and and then
be able to go to the full committee to
present it does that cross all the te's
eyes everybody okay with that okay Mr
Miller you have something you want to
add could you please come here because
there are people who are watching this
breath thank you and um I think some of
my prior points Also may not have made
clear but I'm relatively happy with the
outcome
um the reason that I was mentioning the
history in Europe was not just for
trivia um but because uh the of the
importance of uh each node in the graph
of a data flow having in flowchart so to
speak uh having these similar
protections and uh we do have a mix
under the proposal of optins and opt
outs and that is almost fine because uh
optins are generally considered to be
stronger than opt outs but there
is one thing
missing in the way optin is
defined in 314 compared to other similar
legislation so in adpa the federal
bipartisan bill that didn't get past
Pelosi um excuse me oh there's a federal
bill called the American data protection
Privacy Act uh that has not yet been
passed corre correct there was a lot of
bipartisan support but it didn't get
past um the the chairwoman okay so in
that bill uh similar to what uh we're
trying to you're trying to do here um
with this combination of of the two um
portions of of the RSA statute um there
are a certain set of stronger
requirements that apply to these uh
large social media companies Etc and
there's a different set of requirements
for the smaller
ones
but there's also a data minimization
requirement and what that means
is it's a mechanism to prevent what's
called consent fatigue consent fatigue
is when every few minutes you get a
popup that says hey you want to let us
do this thing with your data and then
when you don't click it a few minutes
later you get another one and ultimately
it's very hard to enforce your rights if
you think you can't use a service unless
uh every few minutes you're willing to
SW something away that's bothering you
right so data minimization is a fairly
basic part of data Protection Law for
the last 50 years and this is the
requirement
that it is actually a data controller's
burden to make sure that they're not
asking for more than they need to
provide the service and that is missing
here from both 314 and
255 and by leaving that out we create a
government the government creates an
incentive in the private
sector for companies to try to use
consent fatigue to obtain consent for
excessive collection processing and
transfer of information and that is a
concern that I have with the current
proposed
setup thank you could you tell me in the
um to try to fill the void by lack of
action in the federal level is that data
minimization um uh in each of the State
uh
laws uh data minimization has
been successfully lobbied out of the
majority actually that's not what I
asked I asked is it in the state law it
is in California yes in California and
uh the subsequent bills have been
crafted to not include it um it is under
consideration in uh the Massachusetts
and Main legislatures at present which
has a potential to influence uh Regional
compliance great thank you that is very
helpful
information appreciate that anybody yes
representative tur yeah just just one
question on that point and I think goes
back to the point I was interested in
earlier with the concept in 255 of
universal opt-in or Universal opt out
does that mitigate the consent f
question without the concept of
minimization um not unless there's a uh
clear legislative uh imperative to uh a
clear imperative in the legislation that
companies cannot employ consent fatigue
to attempt uh to gain consent and uh
it's not clear to me that that are you
referring to particular wording that you
requirement my understanding in 255 was
that the way it's worded it would allow
there to be technology used that would
allow you to sort of universally opt in
or universally opt out whatever be your
preference for
um for data sharing in in in general and
so I didn't know whether essentially it
would be something you would set say in
a browser my understanding that you that
would be then applied across the board
and and hope I'm understanding that
correctly so because I I agree with the
concept of consent fatigue being you
know a difficulty both for privacy and
for just the logistics of of people's
lives uh that's an excellent point so
with regard to that particular portion
of 255 my concern here is that the
um that doesn't correspond to that
doesn't apply to the protection in 314
if wording were to be added in 255 that
would ensure that those requirements
applied also to the opin provision of
314 that might depending on the wording
address this concern but one additional
thing that I'd like to to mention is I
think you know on all sides of this
issue everyone agrees that legislation
and Technology move at different the
legislative process and Technology move
at different Paces right and uh sure
when we talk about browsers um there is
a thing called do not track that
resulted from years of negotiations by
people setting web standards in a lot of
different countries Milla Foundation was
a big actor but it was their own kind of
private sector standards legislative
process and the fact is that people
access the internet from a lot of
different Services there is no such flag
on all mobile os's there's no such flag
on Internet of Things there's no such
flag on your refrigerator that people
can hack to get your email so um and we
have no idea what what signals will be
available to be sent from various
devices and programs a year from now so
um relying on that may not
work thank you thank you very much
anything
else if not um then
um we'll end this
subcommittee um meeting we will meet
again at um and it will be posted at at
um
9:45 on
the morning of November 8th at which
time um we will vote on um our proposed
255 and does that I think does that
complete our business does anybody have
anything else that they'd
like no then
um we we
are finished we're
you